what's up everybody welcome to day three
the final day of e3 2015 for GameSpot
Krauss kind of funny I'm one of your
host Greg Miller alongside the pride of
Long Island Col Moriarty Greg and then
from Rocksteady Studios Sefton Hill
House now you have a very special very
special e3 cuz you're here it's the
final two AV three and then Tuesday your
game comes out not only is it just your
game
it's Batman Arkham Knight which I
realize not only is it Batman which
everybody loves it's the finale of your
Batman story how do you feel
yes it's kind of really strange to be
coming to the end of you know the
trilogy way we really wanted to go out
with a bang and create something you
know we spent three-and-a-half years
making it so we wanted to make a big
explosion finale for sure it feels
really weird to be honest because like
for the last eight eight eight eight and
a half years like every day I just wake
up and think Batman like Batman Batman
how do we make the game better what do
we do what do we do so it's gonna be
it's really weird already to not be
thinking like that you know to be sort
of you know I've said it probably sort
of feels like a marriage breakup you
know because I've it literally it's an
obsession so I mean is it that I mean
like at this event you're showing the
game like you've been done with the game
for a while I imagine right yeah that's
right yeah we're done with you know go
master this burn
yeah shot millions of copies out there
in the wild now so yeah we've been done
for a little while not that long but for
a little while so we're just
acclimatizing now and sure to life after
end and so then what happens now at the
studio I know you have a whole bunch of
DLCs yeah they're for this year are you
right into their mode is there a bit of
a break we're right into DLC like quite
a lot of the studio working on stuff for
the season pass and we have this idea of
the monthly cadence for the seasons
season pass so six months of content one
content drop every month so a lot of the
studio working on that and then some of
the studio thinking about what's next
but like that's way off in the future
so I think my biggest question pertinent
to e3 was did anyone try to stop anyone
with the Arkham the Arkham City spoiler
to start your trailer at Playstation or
we used like well you had your chance to
play this I mean it was it's kind of a
key thing because a lot of people are
asking like is Joker really dead yeah
what happens next and so we really
wanted to start off and say like he's
really dead like I just wanted to make
that clear so there was no confusion
about about that fact right from the arm
so that's how that was kind of the
reason to start with that and we wanted
to go you know we wanted to the starts
kind of a signature moment for us where
we want to set up the whole game so we
had the idea of the diner sequence as
well because we wanted to show the
psychological attack of scarecrow and
show what that means to actually be hit
by the fear toxin yeah and we wanted to
show you that first person as well and
yeah did we think of it I guess I think
we think about spoiling Arkham City and
you had a good chance right that's my
thing don't get me wrong : I you are on
this spoiler crusade all the time that
there has to be a time limit and if
you're like the only person I know who's
like oh man I got a beat Arkham City
soon before I can move on to our crime
he's my girlfriend so she had Christine
you had your chance to find out huh I
know right well this was the question I
was asking recently was you know we were
born in 1980 well during Empire ya know
Empire came out and Vader was revealed
as Luke's father yeah what was the you
know what could at the timeline been at
that point like when it was okay to say
something your friends at a party 1983
or so from the ground when Jedi camera
in other words there has to be a time
that lasts right so yeah I agree with
you get over it if people are obsessed
over it Boadicea - yeah yeah yeah I mean
if you're not there in a year you're
just not trying one of the things I'm
curious about with your studio in
particular is that you know you guys
always had great talent you know
starting with Arkham Asylum but you guys
are really considered one of the great
premiere triple-a studios now as you
guys move into this third game so what's
what's the climate like at the studio in
that regard you guys feel a lot of
pressure building up in terms of like
delivery because when you know Arkham
Asylum came out there really were no
expectations and yeah there are massive
expectations with organizing yeah it's
strange that I think the best way to
deal with it is we ignore it because I
think if you realize how many people are
going to play the game
and focus on that it's mind blowing you
know like it's a cloud to comprehend you
know and so we just try and make the bet
I think really what we learned on Arkham
Asylum is we just got to be true to our
instincts and make the game we want to
make and that's what people enjoy and
don't try and second-guess the market or
try and water stuff down or try and
change it you know just just make the
experience we think we enjoy you know
honestly I just make the Batman game
that I want to play like totally driven
by that and and that we hope then that
people feel that passion and love and so
it's there's no kind of focused testing
of ideas sure what's going to work here
or what's going to work you know is it
going to work for this market or these
people it's very specifically you know
cuz it's very specifically that vision
quite small studio about a hundred
developers so compared to the studio's
that we compete against you know five
hundred six hundred nine hundred a
thousand so what we try to focus on is
that passion and attention to detail and
coherency and everything that I think
makes this a bit different though
because we're one studio we're all
sitting in the same offices we don't
really outsource a lot of work I have oh
that we can have a sort of a much better
shared vision I think about what we're
making is it I mean you're talking about
you know the marriage is breaking up is
it easier do you get nostalgic all the
time to think about eight years ago like
when you're I remember when you guys
came through IGN for the first time yeah
in me and Anthony guy who's who was
working for gamespy's the time we went
in there and watched the demo and we
left and he goes this is the first time
I ever talked to him I wanted one of my
good friends he's like that seemed
pretty cool and I remember going was it
like I can't tell cuz it was like here's
the here's the combat you're doing this
and you reverse and it's just a few
buttons a few buttons then you're done
like that seems interesting but cool and
then all right now we're into predator
mode and you're up and they're like how
does these how does this connect in any
way like I remember that was the thing
is like you guys were seem like
bootstrap guys and it wasn't until I got
the game right and I was reviewing it
runs like oh this is something
incredibly special like do you look back
at that and be like you can't believe
you are now or you're like this you are
the premiere right video game comic book
franchise I mean we never thought when
we made asylum that it would get the
reaction it got
it was it's kind of hard to describe but
really we just work in a bunker like two
years and you get no real feedback and
it wasn't until very late in development
I remember going to idols our publisher
at the time and you know idols in the US
and I was demo in the game and we flew
over we had a few meetings I was demoing
the game to a few people I was actually
one person in the meet I'm demoing the
game and then he went out like a demoed
for a couple of minutes and he went out
and got someone else and said I think
you should see this this yeah and then
he went out and got another couple of
people and then by the end of the demo
it's like a 45 minute demo the room was
packed
standing room only of people like you
got to see this so it was it wasn't
really until that started happening that
we were like oh wow like you know this
is people really like this yeah that's
such little perspective on what you make
yourself and see it every day so but
yeah I mean it was it was great to get
that reaction and that feedback from
people and like I said it was really
about I think just trying to get as much
love you know I love for the character I
love for the universe in there and hope
that people really felt that when they
played it how hard has it been to outdo
yourself for City and now for tonight
because I remember what a Asylum
finished I was like that was awesome but
how can they do this again because you
put so many Easter eggs and references
and files and character it you know I
mean like the whole thing is it was like
a love letter to Batman face how can you
write a second letter in a third yeah
that's a good question and I think that
that's definitely one of the big
challenges you know yeah we always feel
were kind of competing with ourselves
and the way we look at it is that we try
not to make out-and-out sequels
we always try and approach it like we're
making a new game so this games going to
have as many new ideas in it as the last
game we made and obviously we've Arkham
Knight we had the Batmobile on how that
switches up all of the gameplay and it's
not something you know the easy route is
you just make a small Batmobile section
we wanted it to be totally implicit in
every other gameplay mechanic in the
game so that meant rewriting lots of
stuff and reintegrating that into
everything that we've done and that
that's the biggest challenge I think is
making sure that we are always making
those big steps on that it doesn't feel
like I see you know a sequel it feels
like a new fresh experience right then
and we always tell people for the
the best when they pick it up and play
yeah you can see it but playing it is a
much much richer experience and that was
the thing I think you know when you guys
first showed it to us it was when I got
to see it I should say it was the
Batmobile right before the review and
you're going through and I'll never
forget it because it was a Dax right he
was running through and he was doing
he's all animated he's talking he's loud
because that's what Dex does and he's
going and then the game crash right yeah
he's like well sorry it's an early build
and he started back up and then he took
a different route and he was still
smashing through things and I was like
oh because you see that you think oh
this is can yeah like you're going down
this one thing and these stairs are
breakable Matt's bragelonne
but no everything in Gotham City was
completely destructible it was like oh
okay like as soon as people get to play
this game or just see it you know I mean
because right now you have to be cutting
trailers in a certain way as to they
reveal everything right and I have to
imagine is that one of the hardest parts
that you have this story driven game
you're telling this Batman story but you
can't tell us what happens two three
four hours into the game I mean that's
the funny thing and there's so much
pressure to release that and you know I
hate like I would hate to make films
because someone gets your film that you
spend like three years making and then
they just ruin it all in a trailer right
yeah you know like trailers for films
and it's kind of my pet hate and you
know fair play to born I said to born a
right at the start of the project but
there's like a red list of content but I
never want to be used to promote this
game so we just threw up a big red list
called the red list and red and green
lists during this you can talk about red
list no one to talk about while
promoting this game exactly for that
reason and they're like but you know
stories one of your big things that
story something that everyone likes
about your game so you're sure you don't
want to tell people about the story and
it's like but I think they like it
because we don't ruin it as well that's
part of the fun of it so so we have the
red list so everything we've shown in
the game is really within the first two
hours of the whole game there isn't so
we've not really showed anything beyond
that and some of the biggest things in
the game we've not shown at all so
there's a lot of for people to see and
experience and that like I said I kind
of gotta give fair credit to warn out
because the easiest way to sell the game
would be to show that stuff because it
looks amazing yeah
but then you take away from the player
experience so I'm constantly fighting
for like let's just not take away from
that and they they've back that you know
which is great so talk to me a little
bit about how that because this is the
thing for me and this is you know
obviously I can only speak to it cuz
that's only one I've played since you
won't send me a copy at night yet but
for Batman Arkham origins right which
was done by WB Montreal yeah they had
that exact same thing where it was like
you thought you were getting a black
mask game right yeah even you got in and
it immediately flipped like it wasn't
that at all was that something you feel
like was akin to your games before or
you take you did you think that was a
cool move and you're trying to
incorporate that in the night or is that
just like coincidence now we've always
tried to keep sheep as secrets in the
game you know in the first game we never
showed anyone we never let press write
about any of the Scarecrow moments from
a big signature moment in the game
obviously with the fake crash yes Island
being a big key moment and you know we
never even though we knew those moments
got the best reaction when we demoed the
Rose we never showed those publicly or
never you know we never showed those to
be written about so yeah it's always
something that we try and have some
secrets in in city we started as Bruce
Wayne rather than Batman which was lost
and had the twist there and we never
showed that and so there's always
something that we're trying to keep and
keep people on their feet and this one I
think we push that even further you know
so and with the internet the way it is
now and the way people get copies early
and speed around comes and how easy it
is for something to spread yeah I'm
really happy we've got to where we've
got to without too much getting yeah
area and yeah so I'm curious about it I
don't know how to ask this question but
it's something we've talked about in the
past you guys and also W be considered
can continue to call it the trilogy yeah
for games and you guys didn't make one
of them immensely yeah where does that
game fit in I know it's you've made a
divorce analogy before or whatever like
it's like almost like watching someone
else probably take your baby and do you
know like raise it for a little while
and then bring it back a few years later
or whatever obviously you're working on
the game at the time for yourself but
what it like why is it why is that not
game considered part of what you guys
have been doing even though I know you
guys can develop it through I mean that
games definitely Canon I say that for
sure 100% that game is canon the reason
we call it the trilogy is it's the
Rocksteady trilogy of Arkham games I
mean it's not meant in
negative way it's just when they worked
on that game we said what's gonna give
you the best results is if you make the
game that you're most passionate about
and you don't have asked from London
ringing you up in Montreal and saying no
change this do that change that because
to be honest like we're a bit of a pain
in the ass to work you know like we're
very very particular about things and
that and if you work remotely with us
that can be difficult because you're not
getting that instant constant feedback
and we kind of had just all agreed that
we're going to probably strangle
development of the game because we'll
just keep coming back and saying this
isn't the way we'd do it and that
doesn't mean it's the only way to do it
like we have a house style very specific
things we do and don't do all the demos
we ever show a straight cuts from the
game like we never will demo you'll
never see an e3 demo of a Rocksteady
game which is like a fake bit of the
game it's a real bit of the game that
you're gonna play the actual experience
and we don't have time to go and make
like fake III demos but and and so in
that vein you know there there's there's
definitely very much a house style in
the way we do things but we didn't want
to try and force them to add ear to a
style you know because that we just felt
that word strangle and at the end of
they said we always refer to is the
trilogy because it's you know eight and
a half years of our life making three
games but what the game they made is can
and there are lots of references in
Knight to the things that happened in
origins as well like we have a GCPD lock
up you can go to evidence room where you
can see all the evidence of all of the
people Batman's locked up in the course
of the previous three games and then
there's a whole new section for everyone
you're going to capture in this game and
a sale where you get to lock them up so
it's like your trophy room but it's like
a living breathing trophy room sure you
have to sell all that you know starts
off empty and at the end there are like
hundreds of guys in it that you've
locked up and every time you go past
they're all shouting at year and that's
all yeah it's a really great feeling as
you fill that place up so what's on the
red list now I do have a question
silhouette but like you guys are the
best I feel at putting secrets in your
game you don't I mean and like obviously
a lot of people think a calendar man
that was a great one you go
that but I always think of you know
Arkham Asylum when years after release
somebody found that wall and blew it up
and it found the blueprints for Arkham
City yeah
are you putting anything like that are
there secrets in this game similar to
that yeah there's a lot of stuff in this
game and there's some stuff tried to be
cryptic about this yeah I know I I don't
want you to ruin it for me let alone
them there's even a couple of things in
city that when you play this game you'll
think that kind of has an extra
relevance when you play you know a
couple of moments that you look back
when I'm thinking all right I kind of
that makes more sense now in how that
works in this game you know so yeah and
but there's a ton of Secrets there's
probably more references secrets Easter
eggs in Knight than they were in asylum
and city added together you know there's
a ton of those things to fine Oh Colin
Oh Colin one of the you know I'm not a
huge comic book fan but I have a big
Batman fan yeah one of the things that
was always drew me to Batman is Greg and
I talk about a lot as the villains I
love the villains and Batman that's you
have this array of villains to choose
from right you guys have already taken
once I think we've been heard of before
is it more of a casual Batman fan and
done something with my calendar and yeah
how do you how do you choose and like do
you want to elevate some of these more
obscure characters into like more
prominent roles like if not necessarily
a Joker role but more of like you know a
secondary like Riddler or freeze kind of
role and how do you pick from that that
large list going back decades yeah I
mean I think what's great with Batman is
undeniably the best Rose Gallery of any
character in the world so like for us as
a design team being able to pick these
different people to challenge Batman in
different ways and that's why I think I
guess that's fundamental what's great
about the Rose Gallery is that they're
not just a series of good characters but
there's a series of characters who
represent a challenge to part of
Batman's makeup in different ways so
we're picking the people that give us
the most interesting game plan can tell
the most interesting story about the
individual ways they challenge Batman
and because there's such a great
selection of them that's what allows you
to just pick the people who do that best
and we didn't kind of come with a
prerequisite to feature any specific
character and there's no kind of
directive to do that but
there's just so many great characters
that you can't help but kind of right
for them and introduce them and and they
kind of what's really interesting
writing for them is that they take on a
life of their own and they sort of
demand to be in the story because of who
they are so you're writing the story and
thinking all right well two-face would
do this here you know any sort of turns
up because because he's in your head and
you're thinking all right well your face
wouldn't stand for that very dangerous
no that's awesome
I like that yes the thing is why it
feels natural I think why the story
changes together the way it does right
the way you're playing through and
you're on the myth the main storyline
and then yeah oh crap is this thing
that's we need to hush starts and I got
to go do that and all these different
things spiraling off yeah so my question
here starts with a compliment then it
seems but I wanna I'm pre loading with
the confidential question will meet me
out exactly again it's called buttering
you up and then you're gonna get me in a
chokehold exactly I don't know if you
know this okay big Batman fan yes big
Rocksteady so like when you guys
announced you're doing the season pass
DLC I was like great a chance to give
you guys more money I totally trust you
don't screw it up totally trust you and
want you to go do this and then there's
a brouhaha on the internet and then up
to your credit and WB's credit I think
you guys come out and do the right thing
the awesome thing where you come out
you're like hey understood here's what
you're getting yeah
were you surprised by the reaction of
the internet when that what happened I
mean honestly I think season passes are
always a slightly touchy subject and I
was surprised I was surprised because I
know the game yeah so I know how big
this game is like it's freaking huge
biggest game we've made by a miles yeah
so you know I know people are like have
you taken content out there's not one
line of dialogue that's been taken out
for DLC
yeah the DLC is a totally different
beast total its own budget and its own
schedule and the team moved on to that
when work on the main game was done so I
can see why people are like oh you can't
stuff out the main game are you cutting
this thing up to show me something
different it's kind of hard to say to
them look we're not you know it would
been easy to do that because this game
is big and we could have we could have
chopped it up you know it that would
have been something that you could do
and we didn't do that or we could have
chopped it up and giving you some of
that stuff and told you it was for free
and really you're still paying for it
you know but we didn't we were like we
want you to experience this whole thing
as we wanted it to be experienced as one
holistic piece yeah from the start so I
guess I don't know if I was really
surprised but I just wish that people
could see what they're getting you know
like it's really hard to kind of put in
words the size of game they're getting
how it's three and a half years of
development and a three and a half years
of our life and soul into the game so
you know no one is you know you're
getting a great deal when you buy Batman
Arkham Knight much bigger than anything
we've made before so yeah you know it's
I can understand the reaction if you
can't see what in darkness the lens
projects I understand it but trust me
when you see the end product no one is
going to be thinking I'm not getting
value for money for over 60 bucks and
the pricing games hasn't changed for
ages and what you get for 60 but it is
really impressive well it's just the
fact that I think with Arkham City you
guys nailed what I wanted at a DLC right
it was like challenge maps that's always
the part that doesn't do anything for me
yeah yeah well I don't Platinum your
games just like I don't know weighted
madam I put the controller down but when
you're like we're gonna do this and
we're gonna give you this Harley Quinn
story right we're gonna give you story
DLC down the line yeah knowing that
season pass I want to support you guys I
wanted to be a part of it right and then
when you come out here I gets back girl
I was like yeah I'll pay a hundred
dollars just for that mission I don't
care you don't I mean so now tell me
exactly what's happening with Batgirl I
want to know everything off the red list
you confirmed it's Barbara Gordon which
of course I called you look at it it's
clearly Barbara I don't know why the
internet tried to fight me on that I had
a different thought about the green list
of the red list now that they're
literally red and literally green bow
but actually only red red and literally
green what a presentation made actually
all red and green what if a colorblind
person at Rocksteady r WB looks at this
and they're like oh this is the green
list and this is the red list so they
can just imagine they say red list don't
talk about this it's not just colors
here's two lists figure it out it out
once says like the ending that's weird
that's on the green but yeah so what can
you tell me about the bad girl stuff cuz
I love that girl big bat girl fan are
you reading the new backer or run I'm
not yet now they're kind of my special
treat such a treat anyone cycling yeah I
mean not too much but unfortunately I
can tell you about it you said I believe
it's Barbara it's a prequel basically
yeah it's a pretty cool show it's
obviously Barbara as Batgirl before the
story of this game and it's sort of her
when she's kind of fully set up as
Batgirl okay like established
established and she's kicking ass and we
wanted to show you know you get to see
Oracle and everything she's done she's a
big mainstay of the three games so we
wanted to show you what was this
character like before she became or a
correct right and tell that story so it
was kind of their great chance to do
that show her show the relationships as
that existed sort of eight to ten years
ago so that's all before this game that
way before the events of this game way
before she was Oracle kind of post
origins pre asylum back in seven you see
all the right things you just kept me so
excited I'm gonna shut down next week
Colin yeah he used do all the shows by
yourself I could I hope we get more than
one copy but if not okay I need more
than one copy I'm waiting for all right
please but we'd like him overnighted so
that when we get home this weekend we
play we won't we're not gonna do
anything ahead of time you got something
pat him down he's got copies we're in
our final two minutes go so as you I
want you in just you know working on the
DLC and all this other stuff where do
you guys find yourself and I know this
isn't I'm not actually asking for
spoilers right where do you find
yourself in terms of what you want to do
next is that do you have other projects
and you have ideas for or is it like
you'll get to that later we have a lot
of ideas at the moment and what's quite
unusual I guess a lot of people would
know exactly what they're gonna do and
they'll be planning and what we wanted
to do was finish this and put all our
effort into finishing this you know the
traditional games model is you have to
two projects and you kind of run from
one and then the second one starts after
another as the first one finishes and we
don't really were like that we were a
hundred percent until this is done
then we all have a bit of a holiday and
then we come back and we work on the
next thing so we don't have that
traditional crossover just cuz I think
it's really hard making games and you
can't kind of do 50% of your time on it
you got to be a hundred percent focus to
make the best game you possibly can so I
am honestly not lying to you when I say
we're not we're figuring out what we're
gonna do next we're figuring out exactly
what we want it but we want that to be
all right Sefton it's gonna be cool I
love you
they're amazing tell everyone Rock
Steady's amazing I can't wait k house
sent two copies it's out on Tuesday cool
then you finally get to take a
much-needed rest
thank you so much for coming by it's
pleasure thank you ladies and gentlemen
this is gamespot cross kind of funny
let's go see what Alfredo and Chloe are
up to